bella thorne celebrated her 19th  birthday wild and free  The Scream star documented her bday  activities on snapchat Saturday showing  herself having this painful procedure  done oh my gosh here's a close-up of  Bella tearing up after getting her  septum pierced at a tattoo shop also  revealing a hickey on her neck after her  piercing the actress came home to a big  bouquet of red roses literally like she  shared this pig struggling to hold up  the arrangement captioned breaking my  back trying to lift these thank you baby  so who is the special someone that  delivered the gorgeous gift I don't even  know Bella has been rumoured to be  dating Tyler Posey after the pair was  caught kissing earlier this week the  Teen Wolf star Instagram this shot of  him shirtless in bed next to Bella  writing happy birthday my love sorry I  was a couple hours late I was too  distracted by your face